Je puise mon inspiration des problèmes de ma vie quotidienne.
Par exemple,
un jour, j'avais besoin d'un costume pour aller à un festival de la BD,
mais je ne voulais pas dépenser trop d'argent,
donc j'ai fabriqué mon propre costume...
avec une guirlande lumineuse et une jupe.
(Rires)
Une autre fois,
j'étais anéantie parce que mon jeu préféré sur mobile,
Flappy Bird,
avait être retiré de l'App Store.
(Rires)
J'étais donc face à un dilemme :
soit ne plus jamais mettre à jour mon téléphone,
soit ne plus jamais jouer à Flappy Bird.
(Rires)
Comme aucune de ces options ne me séduisait,
j'ai fais ce qui me semblait la seule chose à faire.
J'ai fabriqué une version physique de Flappy Bird
impossible à retirer de l'App Store !
(Rires)
(Musique)
(Signaux sonores)
(Rires)
Et comme certains de mes amis étaient également accros au jeu,
je les ai invités à jouer.
(Vidéo) Un ami : « Ah ! »
(Rires)
(Vidéo) Un ami : « C'est quoi ce truc ? »
Et il m'ont dit que mon jeu était aussi exaspérant que l'original.
(Rires)
Donc j'ai téléchargé une démo du projet en ligne,
et à ma grande surprise, la vidéo est devenue virale.
En quelques jours, j'avais plus de deux millions de vues.
(Rires)
Et le plus intéressant, ce sont les commentaires des internautes.
Bon nombre de personnes voulaient fabriquer le leur,
ou me demandaient comment il avait été fabriqué.
Cela m'a confirmé que, par le biais d'un projet créatif,
on peut enseigner l'ingénierie aux gens.
Avec l'argent gagné grâce à la vidéo virale,
nous avons été en mesure de permettre à nos élèves
de faire leur propre jeu dans une boîte.
Bien que le défi fut de taille,
ils apprirent plusieurs concepts nouveaux sur l'ingénierie et la programmation.
Et ils avaient tous très envie d'apprendre pour pouvoir aussi terminer leur jeu.
(Rires)
Avant la boîte Flappy Bird,
j'avais eu l'idée d'utiliser des projets créatifs d'ingénierie pour enseigner.
Quand j'enseignais au collège,
nous avions demandé aux élèves
de construire un robot à partir d'un kit standard.
Et j'ai remarqué que beaucoup d'entre eux semblaient s'ennuyer.
Puis certains commencèrent à prendre des morceaux de papier
et décorèrent leurs robots.
Puis d'autres suivirent,
et s'intéressèrent davantage au projet.
Je me suis donc mise à réfléchir à des moyens plus créatifs
pour présenter la technologie aux élèves.
J'ai constaté que la plupart des kits technologiques proposés aux écoles
peuvent paraître intimidants.
Ils sont tous faits de pièces en plastique que l'on ne peut pas customiser.
En plus, ils sont très chers,
plusieurs centaines de dollars par kit.
Cela ne rentre certainement pas dans le budget de la plupart des classes.
Comme je ne trouvais rien,
j'ai décidé de fabriquer quelque chose avec mes moyens.
J'ai commencé avec du papier et du tissu.
Après tout, on a tous joué avec ça depuis notre enfance,
c'est plutôt bon marché,
et on en trouve partout dans les maisons.
J'ai prototypé un projet
dans lequel les élèves fabriquent une créature qui s'allume
en utilisant du tissu et des yeux qui bougent.
Ils s'entraidaient tous dans la classe,
rigolaient et parlaient du projet.
Et, plus important encore,
ils pouvaient apporter leur touche personnelle au projet.
Grâce au succès du projet,
j'ai continué à développer d'autres projets d'ingénierie
pour piquer la curiosité des élèves.
Et j'ai aussi commencé à essaimer ces projets en dehors du cadre scolaire,
dans la société civile.
Là, quelque chose de très intéressant s'est produit.
J'ai remarqué que de nombreuses personnes de diverses origines
ont commencé à venir à ces stages.
En particulier,
il y avait bien plus de femmes et de gens issus des minorités
que je n'en attendais,
et que l'on ne rencontre pas d'habitude
dans ce genre de stages tournés vers l'ingénierie.
Regardons maintenant les chiffres sur les employés
d'une grande entreprise technologique en 2016.
Les femmes ne représentent que 19 % des employés du secteur de la technologie.
Et les minorités sont sous-représentées avec une part de seulement 4 %.
Ces chiffres ne vous étonnent pas
si vous vous êtes déjà baladé dans le club robotique d'un lycée,
ou dans une classe de technologie d'un collège.
Bien sur, les causes sont multiples
pour expliquer ce manque de diversité dans le secteur de la technologie.
Une des solutions pourrait être
de présenter la technologie aux élèves à travers des projets créatifs.
Je ne dis pas que cela pourrait tout résoudre,
mais cela permettrait à la technologie de toucher des gens
qui au départ, ne s'y intéressent pas particulièrement,
à cause de la mauvaise image qu'ils en ont gardée depuis l'école.
Donc, par où commencer pour changer l'image de la technologie ?
La plupart des élèves pensent que c'est ennuyeux ou désagréable.
J'ai donc toujours conçu mes projets en suivant trois grands principes :
Premièrement : partir de très bas,
pour pouvoir commencer facilement le projet.
Regardez ce tutoriel.
Pour le premier projet, nous demandons aux élèves
de réaliser un circuit sur du papier.
Comme vous le voyez, ce n'est pas long à apprendre,
c'est plutôt facile, même pour des débutants.
Partir de très bas signifie également que nous écartons les obstacles financiers
qui empêchent les gens d'achever un projet.
Ainsi, avec du papier, du ruban de cuivre, une LED et une pile,
on peut réaliser ce projet pour moins d'un dollar.
Deuxième principe : avoir une marge de progression importante.
Cela signifie qu'il y a beaucoup d'améliorations possibles
donc les élèves peuvent toujours être challengés.
Au départ, c'est juste une créature qui s'allume
mais quand vous lui ajoutez des capteurs et des microcontrolleurs
et que vous le programmez,
cette créature interagit avec son environnement.
(Rires)
Et pour finir,
le troisième principe est la customisation.
Ce qui signifie que l'on peut rendre le projet intéressant pour tout le monde.
C'est l'avantage d'utiliser des éléments du quotidien.
Il est très facile de customiser avec du papier et des tissus.
Donc, même si vous n'aimez pas Flappy Bird,
vous pouvez quand même fabriquer votre propre jeu.
(Vidéo) Élèves : Notre jeu est sur Justin Bieber,
parce qu'il est en excès de vitesse
et le but est d'empêcher la police de l'attraper.
(Rires)
(Vidéo) Élèves : mais il est en train de changer donc,
nous, on fait partie de ses fans.
(Rires)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)